[Music]
sorry it's so late let's go oh please
I'm Judy
I'm very sorry but your suite has been
released
what do you mean released where exactly
is it going your account was in arrears
[Music]
I know what kids need they need their
mother can't have the world's greatest
entertainer about here without a drink
Frank Sinatra's hair
Frank is great but he is no Judy garlic
an even get a manager London would offer
you a lot of money talk of the town is
desperate to do a deal with you you're
saying I have to leave my children if I
want to make enough money to be with my
children using Judy there's an audience
out there wait till you sing my mouth
drivin it listen to me
you'll be fine when you go what room
service
I didn't order anything doesn't matter
under there charlie surprise
the kids miss you and they also want to
stay but I'm coming back for them you're
not listening I have someone I can rely
on
[Music]
like that watch you have to be home for
your mommy to put you to bed are you
going to be alright but if I can't do it
again
[Music]
you need to take better care of yourself
you understand everybody has sex Emily
and I've had mine I just want what
everybody wants I seem to have a harder
time getting it
do you take anything for depression for
husband didn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
want
[Applause]
[Music]